الهجمات على المطارات الروسيه بطائرات دون
تيار استهدفت ثلاثه مطارات كما ذكرنا
الاول مطار مدينه كورس وهو مطار متوقف عن
استقبال الرحلات المدنيه منذ بدء لعمليه
العسكريه الروسيه في اوكرانيا اما الهجوم
الثاني وفقا لوزاره الدفاع الروسيه
فاستهدف بطائرات مسيره سوفيتيجا مطري
جاكلي فول العسكري في اقليم رزان على بعد
185 كلم جنوب شرقي موسكو ومطار انجلز في
اقليم ستراتوف على بعد 600 كيلو متر من
حدود اوكرا يعني وهو ما اسفر عن مقتل
ثلاثه جنودروس وقد قالت لاستخبارات
البريطانيه ان قاعده الجويه هي قاعده
العمليات الرئيسيه للطيران طويل المدى
الروسيه وان اسباب الانفجارات في القاعده
الجويه والمطار الروسيين امس غير مؤكده
حتى الان في نقلت صحيفه نيويورك تايمز عن
مسؤول اوكرانيا ان القوات الاوكرانيه
تستهدفت القاعده السابقتين بطائرات مسيره
وانها دمرت طائرتين في احد المطرين